well i think there's quite a lot of as
they say in russia vrania going on uh
you know i think we have seen the
opposite of some of the statements we've
seen a increase of troops over the last
48 hours up to 7 000 we've seen a bridge
constructed from belarus
into ukraine or near ukraine and i think
we should as i've said we'll take them
at their word but we're going to judge
russia by their actions and at the
moment the troop buildup continues your
buildup continues too you've just sent
more troops more equipment to
estonia isn't that just going to
antagonize the russians at a time when
you say you want donald trump not at all
what we're trying to say to russia is
the consequences of this mass buildup
nearly 60 percent of russia's land
combat forces on the border of a
sovereign nation will get you the
opposite effect in 2014 when you
illegally invaded ukraine
and crimea you ended up with more troops
on your borders more defense spending
throughout nato that's what will happen
that's the strategic error uh that putin
is potentially about to make if he does
invade and i think it's really important
that he understands that nato is
completely united on this we are deadly
serious in how we're going to face the
threat that is currently being posed to
both ukraine and potentially to our
security and that's why we've been here
today and yesterday making sure that we
are all in step which we are to make
sure the message is clear to the kremlin
the nato defense secretary general
yesterday
talked about
the biggest crisis in europe since the
end of the cold war and that this is a
new normal is this a new normal building
up troops on either side and facing each
other off
well i think what is certainly becoming
tragically normal is uh the kremlin
using malign activity and threats to try
and get its way and we've seen that both
in the physical invasion of crimea
and the occupation of that part of
ukraine we've seen that right now with a
hundred you know fifty thousand plus
troops on the border of a sovereign
state you know that is not normal in
anybody else's book uh of course nato
has to respond to that of course europe
has to respond to that uh you know this
is not a a joke or a light matter this
is a a real challenge to the stability
of europe and one of the ways we can
make sure there is no overspill or
escalation is to provide resilience to
our partners at nato and that's what
we're all doing